david rigoulet roze il est rédacteur en
chef de la revue aux rayons stratégiques
bonjour on a envie de rigoler rose merci
de répondre à nos questions en direct
sur arte france qu'est ce qu'il faut
attendre de cette rencontre
d'aujourd'hui à doha je veux dire il ya
déjà eu ce type de rencontre par le
passé il ya eu ce que l'on sait à savoir
le retour des talibans au pouvoir
oui mais si l'on raconte importante
parce qu'effectivement c'est la première
après le retrait effectif des états unis
on peut on peut évoquer la rencontre qui
a eu lieu en août 1 avec
le général mc kenzie et puis le chef de
la cia quelle sphère déplacement express
là c'est la première fois effectivement
après la transition
il ya un gars les éléments de langage
qui sont qui sont affichés effectivement
c'est l'idée de faire pression sur le
régime taliban pour la protection des
droits des femmes des filles pour
l'accès humanitaire parce que la crise
qui se profile avec risque d'être
terrible mais en arrière-plan il ya
aussi une vraie inquiétude de la part
des états unis concernant le risque
terroriste et pas seulement de l'état
islamique du khorassan mais également de
d'al qaïda et d'ailleurs c'est pas un
hasard si le numéro 2 de la saga est
vrai est présent ça doit justement cette
réunion survient au lendemain d'un
nouvel attentat meurtrier attribué aux
groupes terroristes dans les shows
khorassan c'est une coïncidence selon
vous cette attaque terroriste juste
avant
ce sommet les talibans est ce qu'ils
vont demander de l'aide aux américains
pour tenter de lutter contre cette
branche qui aident djihadistes du groupe
terroriste état islamique bah en
l'occurrence les talibans qui se sont
engagés vis-à-vis des américains
justement dans le cadre de l'accord de
doha de février 2001 à éradiquer ils
l'ont fait d'ailleurs aussi à l'endroit
des russes à éradiquer le la présence de
l'état islam de la branche effectivement
du khorassan de l'état islamique en
afghanistan
mais mais il ya une succession de
d'attentats ces derniers ces derniers
jours qui pose le problème qui touche
les talibans là où le bât blesse parce
que en réalité de la légitimité d'état
des banques affiché c'est d'abord en
termes de sécurité et là manifestement
ils éprouvent des difficultés pour faire
prévaloir cette sécurité dans au niveau
de l'ensemble du pays et quels seront
les arguments de part et d'autre on sait
quels étaient les talibans recherche la
reconnaissance de la communauté
internationale que recherchent
exactement les états unis à travers ces
rencontres cette rencontre et simplement
les droits humains non c'est ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure parce qu'il ya
le david cohen qui est numéro deux de la
cia et a fait une déclaration le 14
septembre dernier un dans un dans un
meeting consacré renseignements ou
constaté des regroupements justement
deux d'al qaïda et donc pas seulement de
l'état islamique et là va se poser la
question de la crédibilité effectivement
des engagements des talibans par-delà
même effectivement le
les exigences en matière de droits des
femmes et et de deux gouvernements plus
inclusif pour l'instant c'est pas c'est
pas à l'ordre du jour en réalité il ya
on est dans l'urgence à la fois en
termes sécuritaires et humanitaires
à lors de cette réunion vous pensez que
le contexte humanitaire vous venez de
l'aborder comment sera abordée justement
ce contexte humanitaire parce qu'on a
entendues dans ce journal quelques
instants avant votre interwiew
l'onu qui appelle à ce que l'ensemble
des fonds soient soient débloqués oui ça
fait partie effectivement c'est un des
moyens de pression qu'il ya sur le
régime taliban puisqu'il fait toujours
pas l'objet d'une reconnaissance
internationale même si c'est ce qu'ils
souhaitent évidemment obtenir et là on
est à l'arme financière parce que de
toute façon le pays est financièrement
exemple les talibans sont en mesure de
prendre en charge les enjeux de sécurité
alimentaire puisqu'il ya risque de
famine qui se profile de sécurité en
termes de santé d'ailleurs ils ont
demandé aux ong 2 2 ce matin de
maintenir leurs activités sur place
c'est à dire qu'ils sont en mesure
effectivement prendre en charge le pays
comme comme il pourrait le faire et donc
à une fragilité et donc il ya un espèce
de logique transactionnel effectivement
par rapport aux taliban alors disant
écoutez si vous voulez une aide que dont
vous pouvez pas faire l'économie il faut
aussi ajuster vos
engagements concrètement ce qui pour
l'instant n'a pas hésité encore vraiment
le cas
cette rencontre elle intervient de
manière très rapide pourquoi cette
rencontre formelle sitôt est ce que
c'est une opération de communication
dont une réelle volonté de s'entendre
sur des sujets de fond les sujets que
vous venez d'évoquer on va vraiment
avoir des avancées aujourd'hui et demain
en tout cas il ya une logique d'urgence
il ya des impératifs qui sont
effectivement à la fois humanitaire et
sécuritaire ce que j'évoquais et donc
non là on n'est pas dans une logique de
communication c'est réellement pour
obtenir quelque chose d'acquis salle du
côté des américains on se retire mais
d'un autre côté on reste en regardant un
petit peu ce qui se passe de loin
de loin oui mais ils sont ils sont
conscients que l'enjeu du terrorisme est
en train de se concrétiser si j'ose dire
et donc ils peuvent pas se permettre de
regarder dans toutes deux trop loin ça
explique justement la mobilisation en
question est là j'allais dire la
sécurisation
humanitaire du pays et est une variable
aussi qui rentrent en ligne de compte
pour pour pouvoir obtenir effectivement
un certain nombre d'engagements de la
part du nouveau régime donc tout est lié
en réalité et la question d'une
migratoires qui est évoqué par le
représentant de l'onu évidemment en
filigrane et et bajur également moins
pour les américains que pour les
européens en tout état de cause
justement parlez des européens la sienne
rencontre entre les américains et les
talibans comment les européens
voit cette rencontre aujourd'hui
de toute façon les européens sont un peu
hors jeu malheureusement un dans le
cadre du processus de négociations qui
avaient eu lieu avec les talibans à
chaque étape les américains n'avaient
pas sollicité spécifiquement les
européens et dans les négociations avec
les russes c'était la même chose donc là
on peut noter d'ailleurs que les russes
viennent de faire une habitation aux
talibans aux mêmes talibans pour le 20
octobre prochain avec un format qui
regrouperait la chine l'inde le pakistan
et l'iran toujours avec les mêmes
impératifs en toile de fond à savoir le
risque de déstabilisation du pays et les
impératifs sécuritaires pour les russes
au dos des frontières mais les anciens
pays de l'union soviétique de l'ex de
série mercy d'amerigo les roses d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef de la
revue orient stratégique